[Music]
you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news coming up on today's
programme
does scotland's future include more oil
exploration we hear from scotland's
first minister as a political row
rumbles on
five more years of formula one in
barcelona as the venue commits to take
account of the climate emergency
and on record store day we hear from the
musicians doing their bit to make the
industry more sustainable
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world right now
and challenge those coming up with the
solutions let's start today over at our
data dashboard where you can see that
renewables mostly wind today with some
solar and hydro making up around 40 just
over 40
of british electricity generation right
now what you can't see there is the
regional breakdown and in scotland today
70 percent of their power is coming from
wind with the remainder from
hydroelectric and nuclear power meaning
their energy is all low carbon but
scotland's economy continues to depend
on the export of oil and gas from the
north sea oil fields and a political row
over whether to continue to develop more
rumbles on last week after months of
pressure from environmentalists nicholas
sturgeon voiced her opposition to the
cambo oil field saying the proposed
development should be blocked on climate
grounds
that position provoked something of a
backlash in hollywood james matthews
spoke to nicolas sturgeon earlier today
as the smp's annual conference began
i'm at the whiteley wind farm outside
glasgow the city that these things power
215 wind turbines here generating power
for three hundred and fifty thousand
homes this is eagle chamuer it's also
the uk's largest onshore wind farm
nicola sturgeon has chosen this as the
location to launch her party's snp
conference the november conference she
conducted a round of interviews as she
typically does with journalists i took
the opportunity to ask her about power
not these things but cambo the oil field
of shetland controversial project
ultimately a decision for the uk
government as to whether or not there's
drilling in cambo nicolas sturgeon came
out recently in opposition to it said it
shouldn't be given the green light that
prompted something of a backlash in snp
ranks as well as anywhere else um
colleagues people within the
independence movement said that could
create unemployment it could lead to
imported fossil fuels and ultimately be
bad at the
at the polls for the snp so
controversial
i asked nicola sturgeon about
her opposition to campbell
there are colleagues of yours
in the independence movement some
friends some not so much who say that
your opposition to the campbell oil
field
will lead to unemployment imported
fossil fuels and it could ultimately
cost independence are they right well i
think no other not right they're
fundamentally wrong and i think it's
frankly just a
either a misrepresentation of my
position or an oversimplification of the
issue the starting point here is the
science tells us we need to move away
globally from fossil fuels scotland has
got to play its part on that but the
question is how we do that and the
starting point that is not contested
certainly not in my mind is that we
mustn't leave those who work in the oil
and gas sector right now on the economic
scrap heap and we mustn't become
more reliant on imported oil and gas so
that is how do you make that transition
without either of those things happening
and that is about well let me finish the
point that is about investing in the
alternatives the renewable low carbon
sources of energy doing that in a way
that delivers jobs and and economic
benefit down the supply chain in
scotland is that an easy task no that's
a difficult transition but it is one no
country in the world certainly no
country that is currently producing
fossil fuels can shy away from and
anybody who tries to deny that that
challenge is very real but that we've
got to confront that challenge frankly
is not thinking as carefully and as hard
as they should be about the climate
emergency and the imperative of tackling
that
nicola sturgeon there if cambod does get
the green light drilling could start as
early as next year and continue for 25
years yielding hundreds of millions of
barrels of oil the uk government is in
favour the scottish secretary alistair
jack said recently a hundred percent
campbell should get the go ahead
james matthews there reporting now in
some of today's other climate news 13
people have been arrested after
extinction rebellion activists blocked
amazon warehouses across the uk the
protesters have been staging black
friday demonstrations accusing amazon of
being environmentally destructive the
group blocked multiple site entrances
using bamboo structures and say they
plan to stay for at least 48 hours
thousands of miles of england's
wildlife-rich hedgerows could be under
threat without urgent action to fill new
gaps in farming policy that's according
to the rspb who say that healthy and
well-managed hedgerows provide benefits
to wildlife as well as absorbing large
amounts of carbon essential to tackling
the climate crisis
the spanish will retain a formula one
grand prix until
2026 it was announced today as part of
the agreement the barcelona venue will
implement sustainability upgrades the
catalan minister responsible referred
explicitly to climate change saying we
want the circuit to become an exponent
of the green transformation and the
adaptation of infrastructures to the
demands of the climate emergency
while motor racing doesn't shout climate
friendly formula one is branding itself
as a leader in the field
f1 have undertaken a detailed carbon
footprint analysis and they estimate
that around 256 000 tons of co2 is
generated each race season
remarkably of this only 0.7 of the
carbon emissions comes from the cars
themselves
45
comes from the massive road sea and air
logistics involved in the global events
in 2019 formula one announced the
ambition to be net zero by 2030
under this plan all facilities factories
and venues will be using 100
renewable electricity
logistics and travel efficiency will be
improved to use the least carbon
intensive transport available
and all race cars will be powered by
sustainably fueled hybrid power units
that element begins next season when f1
cars will have to use 10
sustainable fuel
milsi cold one of britain's favorite
fish has lost its sustainability
certification for a third year due to
deep worries about stock levels but now
an online platform has teamed up with
marine conservation charity sea changers
to donate funds to help save cod stocks
stake sir steakster says they'll donate
to the charity every time someone plays
call of duty through their app we're
joined now by tom pickerel a marine
biologist tom so does from the beginning
how did this partnership come about
yeah it's really it's a novel
partnership um stakes that wanted to use
the launch of the new call of duty game
on cod uh as a force for good uh and
obviously the names was the obvious part
and as they looked into it a bit further
um they opened their eyes to the issue
of declining uh cod populations and some
of the challenges that was facing
and what they wanted to do is actually
use this uh launch to donate money to
sea changes so uh that's that's how it
began
why are norsey stocks declining tom
where have all the cod gone
yeah i mean they were really badly
fished in the 90s and into the 2000s and
in year 2005 they were the lowest level
recorded but then an emergency plan was
put in place and it was successful that
the stocks grew and in 2017 as you noted
they they received the marine
stewardship council certification but
then unfortunately two years later it
lost it
and stocks have been going down ever
since now we believe it's probably a
combination of factors uh including
warming waters through climate change
sort of causing the population to move
um
fewer younger fish going into the
population but also overfishing so that
the scientific advice for the catch
levels has been ignored uh for the last
two years
so the aim of the tie-up with call of
duty then tom is about raising funds
raising money but also about raising
awareness to an audience that might not
yet know enough about it
absolutely this is this is the sort of
the parallel key
aim of the of the the initiative is to
really raise awareness uh about this
issue with a new cohort of people an
audience of 18 to 35 year olds sort of
the gaming community
so it's going to be i find that
particularly interesting to see how we
can actually engage with such a
community who probably really mindful of
issues like this but maybe just don't
know the details
tom picker great to hear from you thanks
very much for joining us
thank you
now it is black friday and it's also
record store day that is a day to
celebrate independent music as in any
other sector musicians are increasingly
aware of the environmental impact of
their work let's hear now what some of
them are doing to make the industry more
sustainable
[Music]
i store renewable energy solar energy in
batteries and use that to do my concert
right so i've been doing and have
powered over 800 concerts close to 900
completely by renewable energy i think
that is an element of what makes me a
sustainable artist aside from the actual
music and the message
the reason why we decided to repress our
album on recycled vinyl is a couple of
things really i mean firstly we as a
band
you know our values are very important
to us we believe that you know the kind
of music scenes we come from punk and
metal and rock you know they have a
tradition of being counter cultural of
being political you know and and we
think that one of the most important
you know political challenges that we
can be involved in as a band is the
climate crisis we can be more
sustainable as a band we thought well
why not try it we've got a number of
sections of our merchandise that are
earth positive which is
all the materials for them are ethically
sourced they're 100 organic
we've also on the merch line got our own
water bottles kind of like stainless
steel flasks but listen i mean this is
obviously
you know quite small things but
hopefully if everybody can make small
changes like that then it can have a big
effect
it's down to all of us you know the
climate crisis is an all hands on deck
thing things are hard always but if you
take a step every day toward it whether
it's your dreams and goals whether it's
you know
whatever right sustainability
regeneration we can achieve it together
do stay tuned because coming up after
the break i'll be joined by judy ling
wong honorary president of the black
environment network and business greens
editor-in-chief james murray we're going
to be discussing whether net zero
targets are a reason to be cheerful
and if it's time to shop more
sustainably
[Music]
environment network and business greens
editor in chief james green evening to
both of you now it could be the biggest
black friday yet with shoppers expected
to spend almost 9 billion pounds in
store and online but some retailers are
opting out of the sales altogether this
year saying discount deals encourage
people to buy things they don't need so
is it time shoppers start to think about
the environmental impact of their
bargain deals judy let's start with you
what's wrong with black friday
i don't think judy can hear us james
i'll put that question to you then
what's the matter with black friday and
getting a good deal
it's a really difficult one for
environmentalists because no one wants
to be seen to be um you know being
downbeat about things that people enjoy
you know you don't want to be dictating
to people you don't want to be seen to
be preaching and being dull and and sort
of a bit of a part of people on this
stuff and and that makes it really
challenging but the the problem is that
the level of consumerism that we see
particularly around black friday
particularly when people are buying
things that they don't really need that
serve no real function they're just
there as a real short-term dopamine hit
and that are designed to be used like
once or twice in the case of some sort
of fast fashion items um or deliberately
disposable sort of gifts um that does
have an environmental impact and it's an
environmental impact that you can see
very little upside for so um it's one of
the hardest parts of the net zero
transition it's the area that we're
probably least con least confident
around how we can tackle
the consumerist culture that's so
embedded
into the way the modern economy works
but it is something where new business
models and new approaches are going to
have to be developed if we're to deliver
sort of the deep cuts and emissions that
are needed
and what might those solutions look like
then judy
well some of those solutions really are
supply chains and so on and using
different kinds of energy in order to
produce a product but i think awareness
is the greatest thing many people are
still not aware so they actually don't
choose choosing and campaigning actually
has a huge pressure on business to
create changes the other thing of course
is sheer quantity we shouldn't buy what
we should not need that is something
very simple so without being able to see
the problem on or or anything like that
just by buying exactly what is necessary
that we need will make an enormous
difference in itself yeah i mean there's
a stark figure isn't there that up to 80
percent of black friday purchases are
thrown away after a very short time but
there are some brands judy aren't there
that are going against black friday
yes a lot of brands are actually saying
that we shouldn't be encouraging
unnecessary sales and we shouldn't be
encouraging people to buy things that
damage the planet and we need to be
aware of the vast ranges of damage not
just in terms of emissions but all sorts
of things like plastics and is actually
getting into the food chain wwf tells us
that each one of us every week is now
eating plastic the size of our credit
card i mean that's quite frightening we
don't know the implications yet but it
shows us that if we damage nature
we in the end damage our own lives and
that's a great incentive incentive to
try and do something about it
now governments and businesses around
the world are promising to cut their
carbon emissions to help limit global
warming around 90
of the global economy is now covered by
some kind of net zero target but how
good
are these commitments let's put it to
our panel james that statistic in itself
90 sounds pretty remarkable when you
think where we were
just a few years ago but how credible
are those commitments
the level of credibility varies
massively but the general direction of
travel is hugely encouraging i mean if
you think back sort of five years ago
six years ago when the paris agreement
was uh signed the most ambitious target
in the world was probably the uk's which
was an 80 cutting emissions by 2050. and
now we've got a situation where 90 of
the global economy is covered by these
net zero goals the stated intent of
governments that are responsible for
ninety percent of the global economy is
to effectively fully decarbonize
and where they can't fully decarbonize
expand carbon sinks to compensate um all
activity you've also got four thousand
businesses
or government organizations or
city-states or the like but four
thousand different entities similarly
have these net zero targets in place uh
the companies involved uh command
revenues of nearly 20 trillion dollars
this is like the big global economic
project of the age it's the defining
long-term priority of governments and
businesses all around the world so
there's very legitimate questions about
the credibility of some of these targets
they vary massively in quality some are
really good and are backed by billion
dollar investment plans and are looking
at using new technologies to really
deliver deep decarbonisation others are
literally nothing more than a pledge a
promise that we will do this in the
future um and some are probably being
used to cover up activity that you
wouldn't want to see but
there is real progress here and having
the target is absolutely the first step
to then delivering on it
judy greta tumber's warned about net
zero targets being used as excuses to
postpone
real action how do you guard against
green washing
wells rules and so on are being put in
but really it's very difficult because
people first of all set up their targets
and then they list their offsets and
claim that they will actually compensate
for it the real issue is whether we are
actually putting out emissions at all
because offsets may or may not deliver
and once you release any emission that
is into the atmosphere it will stay
there for 300 to 1000 years so that the
offsets and so on actually failing is an
enormous risk to us and other events add
to the overall picture for the first
time we've seen million acre fires as a
result of climate change burning down
massive old growth forests in the usa
while we're blithely talking about
planting trees were upsetting
james i want one final thought from you
when we talk about net zero it's part of
the common language around climate
action now but how many people genuinely
understand what it means and actually
does that matter
um i think the level of understanding
from the polling is actually much better
than you'd expect because it is a
slightly technical term you know it does
refer to balancing out the emissions
that we have and the emissions that we
soak up and there's a degree of science
behind that um but you know polling by
the uk government has shown a majority
of people are aware of the term they
broadly understand that it means you
know getting to zero emissions the deep
decarbonization
of our economy and and yes and it's
being widely used it's been widely used
in a lot of businesses it's being widely
used by politicians and i think it will
continue to grow in awareness because as
i say is the defining economic priority
that we want to see and just on the fact
that there are these concerns about
offsets and the like the thing is the
vast majority of advocates for net zero
they know that um you know the un
secretary general stood up at cop26 and
said he wants a new working group to
ensure that these targets are credibly
met
there are initiatives that are saying if
you want to say your net zero you need
to cut your direct emissions by over 90
percent you can only use compensation or
offsets for the tiny little bit at the
end that is really difficult to tackle
so um there are legitimate concerns and
we do need to be wary to spot green wash
but there is as i say real progress here
and and some some modest source for
optimism given the scale of the
challenge that we face james murray judy
linguang thank you both very much indeed
that is everything from us for this week
don't forget though you can download our
weekly podcast climate cast this week
we're talking about how we should teach
climate change to children this episode
is a family affair it features my own
children you can take a listen wherever
you find your podcasts
but do stay tuned here on sky news
because coming up next
how the uk and europe are reacting as a
new variant of coronavirus is identified
in south africa thanks for watching see
you next time
[Music]